okay you ready
yeah three two one
wait
what do we do now
i don't know it was so in sync we don't
well we only did it twice but that's
because we were sitting like 100 miles
apart i i'm not very good at
geographical
how much are we sitting in pad now oh
that's a good question
because it needs to be
safe because things that aren't back to
normal yet
it needs to be the two meters
at least at least
this is absolutely terrifying watching
this coming towards me
keep going
[Laughter]
two meters and 20.
perfect did you just lose a finger no
just a bit of pain but that's okay
excellent good good
that's your slide clicker hand
where's my slide clicker it's uh down
there
there you go
right
[Music]
right should we talk about the web talk
about the web come on i'm actually i'm
actually adjacent with this one because
i want to talk about this
yeah mate
you realize in css you can have font
sizes bigger than just install the web
and something must have gone wrong this
is what you get okay so hang on it's
den
oh now this is controversial this is
exactly
why i put it there and didn't say it
myself because you wanted me to make the
mistake yeah youtube you're wrong not me
so because it right it's deno or dino
that much is here it's one of the two
and you know what i did
i went back to this presentation you
know this is oh who this is rather this
is mr dino
isn't it jeremy dino
it's ryan dahl yep roi on github
originally the creator of node
and now also the creator of the thing
yep and this is
jsconf2018
where he announced it and i was in the
audience and i was like
um and he called it denno oh there you
go and surely case closed and i smugly
tweeted just in case
here's proof it's called deno everyone
oh there you go and then denno tweeted
at me
saying like actually ryan is wrong
who's behind that account now apparently
he got convinced it should be called
dino and so it's dino the canonical
pronunciation
is dino it's like gif just so everyone
knows i will probably get this wrong in
this episode i will probably even use
both interchangeably
it's both the same we're talking about
the thing you know the thing i want to
talk about so what is dino well it's
that it's it is basically node it's it's
a javascript runtime but it has
typescript i think that's what most
people already know instead of running
javascript it can also run typescript
it's actually typescript first
and has a bunch of very interesting
not necessarily new takes but just a
combination of things into one which is
a different take on package management
security web compatibility and you know
i thought just give a little little
roundup because i've been playing with
it i've been liking it it's really good
to excite i've used it once in passing
but i don't know a lot about it so i'm
going to start here
yeah
i put it on my cv now
um but it's we've not had a lot of
competition in this space
like there was a hundred years ago there
was the server-side javascript stuff
that
netscape did and then there was nothing
you know that one oh yeah yeah you're
younger than me uh there's a long long
time ago and then there was
node
and now there's deno so it's like this
and so much a change between the old
netscape thing and uh
and node so it's interesting to see what
like what's the you know what have they
learned what have they changed what have
they learned from node and gone you know
what i think they have the talk from
ryan dahl from jascop2018 actually is
explicitly was a talk 10 things i
learned or 10 mistakes i did a note
something like that and he kind of used
a talker then lead into dino um but the
mistakes he talks about are really
interesting we're going to link to that
all right but i just want to basically
just look at dino by itself and just
talk about a bunch of things so this is
don't be intimidated by this oh perfect
yes great this is from there we go their
website you don't need to know this but
there's a couple of interesting things
that you know that i want to extract the
one thing is dino's written rust
that by itself
doesn't mean much immediately although i
have no experience at actually
contributing to dino like hacking around
in the actual engine
it's quite doable you see you just drop
that in now you you're now
no i i i just hacked around you
corrected the spell spelling mistake you
read me right yeah i didn't even i don't
even have a comment
i added a sum function a global oh okay
and that was that was easy enough
and you know that is saying something i
was actually like i have
some i know some rust i'm far from an
expert but the cool thing is the build
system is super easy and if you've ever
tried to build v8 or something like that
you know that that is not easy yeah and
the nice thing is they extract it all
the way it just builds
um and the other thing that i want to
point out it uses v8 so it's our trusty
v8 engine running the javascript
and the other thing that's just you
don't really need to know that but i
found it interesting
in in note most of the file system
functions are direct bindings to c plus
plus backed functions which is where you
often see native function when you see a
stack trace or something
in dino you have exactly two native
functions which are just
able to send buffers to
the isolate background and so you always
have to communicate through these two
functions
that has that is that a good figure or
bad thing it's a good thing because
that's the only way to get out of the v8
sandbox only through these two functions
so the audit surface is very small
unless that function is a vowel
you know so what are we talking here how
i think i think it is interesting that
if if something goes wrong it has to go
through one of these functions you only
have to see
i'm not an expert on this so i'm i
should probably should be terms i found
it interesting that
in contrast to note where loads of
things called directly into c plus plus
you only have two functions or columns
plus here and those are these two
functions for receiving buffers and
sending buffers okay and that's quite
interesting but that's not really
interesting in terms of
us web developers so i want to talk a
bit more about the first thing that's
quite interesting is the standard
library
um you know i know we you have a
extensive environment and so does dino
but you have to import it it's not just
that you have to import it as a url and
the the interesting thing is that that's
an actual url like if you type in this
url into your browser you will see
typescript code appear okay because i i
yeah if you're leaving node behind i
guess you're also leaving npm behind
yes that's true yes pretty much so it's
there is actually no real package
manager in dino because they're like you
know what we're just going to use the
thing that javascript on the web uses
you just import
modules
and that works really well so on the one
hand you see the url is versioned so you
import a specific version of ascended
library which is nice because it
decouples the standard library from the
engine which in node is not the case you
always require fs and that is the fs
that came with your node version so in
this case dino the engine can evolve
without the standard library evolving
which is also i think a benefit for
backwards compatibility you import a
specific version but also there's
obviously a
place to publish user modules
you say obviously
well you have to you you want to be able
to to import code right and can you not
just put this on your own web server
you can and that's what i find they have
this demo.land slash x where you can go
on and publish your own code under a
nice
memorable url
but as i said it's a normal request a
normal ul so you can actually in fact
also point straight to people look at
that or point to your own web server and
that's actually kind of nice it kind of
has this decentralized thing built in
that you don't rely on the central
registry to keep all the code you depend
on so what's the offline story for this
then
another question because obviously you
you want to run a script and you do it
like this you just run and your script
and on the first run that will download
all these files via an actual request
and then look at dependencies and do
that
and then it will never do it again which
obviously sometimes is a problem i mean
if the url is versioned you would hope
it's kind of immutable and the same
version should not deliver different
code in the future so it's not paying
attention to the caching headers
specifically of the request it's i don't
think it is okay i'm actually not 100
sure but
dino has a
command r command f5 whatever built in
by passing a reload flag and then it
will actually reload everything so in
case you do get stuck you can read it
but also it is you know if you want to
develop on
a flight without wi-fi just make sure
you run once before and then
you're pretty good to go so that's my
that's my thinking pose
so
uh how does
dynamic importing fit into this because
that's that's one of those things of
like you're not just going to be able to
say
you know load once then go on your
flight or
remember flights but then because if
it's a dynamic import you do all that
and then
you hit a runtime import and so it fails
dynamic imports work
good excellent um i think for the
offline store you would have to have
them loaded once for them to work
offline i see okay and
i think that's that that's all there is
to it i think it's it's a very it's a
system with very simple rules but there
will be drawbacks at the same time
how often do we really run into this i'm
developing offline
cases well i would say it's quite rare
to have a
when you're running a server
style app having a dynamic import of a
module is pretty rare that your dynamic
imports are more likely to be
adjacent or something like you know
something that is local anyway yeah um
so yeah it's it's yeah for server side i
think it doesn't happen that often and
we will actually see a bit more that
dino is actually going all in on this
like it should probably mostly be static
imports anyway like i feel like dynamic
imports are going to be rare in this
context but they do work i did try it
and that's that's good all right um you
can even run scripts that are non-local
so for example the standard library does
provide a file server something that you
know a node you often have to like
either write or npm install like you can
just run
the url
nice and it will download the script and
run it and all as well you see that um
dash dash allow net
is a flag yes because by default
you can't just access your
network from a script and actually
there's a whole security story here
indeed i want to talk about a bit a bit
more because the security story around
node and npm is sort of terrifying yes
have you heard of post installed scripts
right
exactly
and yeah so as we have no
npm or anything so there is no such
thing but even this has even just
reading files accessing your network
opening a server has a permission story
so for example
here we use the deno global which has
the couple of functions that haven't
found a web compatible home i'm going to
talk about that a bit later but reading
files you do via the deno global
um and it's all promise based also great
promises now that it's it's kind of nice
sometimes to start from scratch isn't it
yeah you can't like catch up on the
developments um and if you run this
script in dino it will fail and tell you
well all will throw rather saying like
you don't have permission to read files
please run me again it's such a nice
default it is just running like npm
whatever it can read anything on your
file system exactly so let's drill that
a little bit more because you know i can
you know i can add allow read and it
will be fine but this is obviously a bit
binary
all or nothing oh you're gonna tell me
it's scoped so what if i did this like i
have a legit reason to read a file so a
person would be quite keen to give me
allow read but then i use my permissions
i abuse my permissions and read my
bitcoin wallet which i don't actually
have but i thought that might tie to
monetary values people actually care
um so if i run it like this it would
work and that would be bad
and what you can do is you can actually
supply this flag multiple times for
every individual file that this script
should be allowed to read so you can
actually give very granular permissions
can it be for like a whole directory or
i would hope so yeah i actually haven't
tried it but even then i would say like
this doesn't necessarily scale because
sometimes you don't know upfront which
files you might want to read or the
script can't potentially even tell you
and this is where something really
interesting comes in i think is that you
can even dynamically request permissions
oh like what we do in the browser pretty
much it is very and that i think is a
story that you see all throughout dino
is that they really took the web model
many learned many many things from the
web because you know the web has really
taken their security quite seriously and
lots of other things that they want to
be secure by default and still be able
to run random sites that you don't trust
like that's a pretty
hard place to start and we have found a
way to make that kind of work um and so
if you do this you you face these
request objects and you pass it to
dental permission request and that will
manifest as a prompt on the cli like
where it goes hey the script wants to do
the thing do you want to permit to do
the thing or would you rather not that's
very good i i would say one thing
like
the browser gets away with
the browser has special ui for
permissions i guess we don't really have
the equivalent in den no a deno program
could output there i think this is an
escape hatch when you don't know which
file or you just
it just doesn't scale with the amount of
files you want to request i'm not quite
sure but i like that there is a way it's
not nice not the most beautiful way
necessarily maybe there will be better
ways in the future maybe at some point
in the future we can actually forward
this permission request to the browser
or something give it a nice common ui
who knows but i mean in that sense it's
early days for dino it's got announced
in late 2018 i think yeah um
it's gotten a good amount of attention
recently but they're still
i think even they're 1.0 it's not that
all so they're still early days and
iterating on all these things and
they're going all in on the web apis as
well so like this streams or what dwg
streams hold on oh okay okay yeah zip
speaking of all right let's talk about a
couple of global objects that are
available in dino and i try to order
them by increasing amount of surprised
face
that
yeah i'm not surprised that global list
is a webstand but it's a it's a
javascript standard yeah right okay not
surprised
okay uh hang on is webassembly in node
as well because you can do web assembly
in node so this is a global in node as
well
no surprise space yeah
and that's a web standard
right so we're talking a little bit more
surprised now because node would have
has its own crypto module
all right but i like that it's using the
compatible api because all this will
boil down to i have more chances to
write i guess this is isomorphic code
code that works without changes on both
sides the server side the client side
that's a good thing yeah all right all
right
nice
not really a surprise well we know node
has workers as well but you have to
import them they're not api compatible
with the web these are
so it's the same
same pattern the web users yeah amazing
yeah well you see i did know this one so
i
not surprised but i was very happy about
this because i
i much prefer the the streams that the
what wgg standardized over there
i just saw a couple days ago no no has
them as well yes they've been they've
kind of
changed their mind a lot of stuff
because they're looking at fetch as well
so
yeah it seems that everything is
converging on standardized apis which is
good that's what standards are for so we
could converge on them absolutely
absolutely
yes okay so node has
some of the things to this now
that's yeah we now have a event target
yeah so node has that as well that's
good oh do they yes yes i did not know
that yeah no you can use signals to
remove event listeners and stuff
fascinating nodes so that's well maybe i
didn't get the order right but still
it's
it
it's based on me having a slightly
lopsided knowledge of of how
node and deno work but location that
does surprise me
as well
nice uh i actually forgot what how it's
exited but i think it is it is
compatible and it mostly reflects import
meta url nice um
yeah excellent
so this is building up to fetch right
i this is where we're going yeah
of course but
these are all the prerequisites for for
having a full actually i fetch in the
list because it surprised me very little
that fetch was in there but i found it
anything at the request response objects
are actually fully so i guess it makes
sense with that it has to be this the
sort of prerequisites and oh
windows on there as well that okay that
is the right i think that is such a
little developer experience sprinkle if
it's literally equivalent to global this
what's the harm yes just to make the
code work that works on both sides
hang on when you um
it's not a worker
does it have window i do not that's
right because i do not know okay i would
have to check that
um and that closes the process process
yeah very good excellent
now what do these do
these are basically similar to
to the permission request they're a cli
mode
variant of these things of course but
yeah like window alert confirm and
prompt will be synchronous and blocking
until the user acknowledges like an
alert needs to press ok confirm
obviously as a yes no or yes no cancel
even and the prompt is type something in
this is fun and exciting it is is there
more uh a bit more there is ah
well
hang on does it persist local storage it
does oh between runs how where is that
it has like if you
deno if you run demo info it will give
you a folder where it stores per origin
data and you have to supply an origin as
a command line flag otherwise it fails
you have to say okay i'm pretending to
run on the origin whatever and then it
creates its own little folder and
everything in local storage will go in
there and on the next run you can read
the data back and don't have to worry
about file system shenanigans this is
amazing is there something more do i
know my own slides i don't know is there
oh there is this my phone
because not only does it have navigator
it has navigator.gp
and this is straight through to web gpu
so yeah i've been looking a little bit
too up to you i'm not going to get into
it but the really the the main new thing
about web gpu is not only it's a newer
sane
approachable api but it decouples
the gpu from canvas
you can use web gpu just for purely
computational purposes and that's
exactly what they're exposing here you
can it's experimental so it's behind an
experimental flag
but
it's exposed just like it is in the
browser and i uh that made me happy
that's so good it's so good so i looking
at this i could really see the whole
okay i can actually
use dino as a stepping stone to write
some code and i can be fairly confident
that it will run on the web as well
later on or the other way around if i've
written web code it's quite likely that
it will also run indeed i can move
modules around
almost seamlessly and i'm kind of not
even talking about typescript much but
you know
dino can run
javascript if it's typescript it will
strip out the it will do the type checks
and sort of the types but in the end
it's just javascript you can also just
import normal javascript as well
nice that's really cool so going back to
the imports and talking a bit more about
standards that we have on the web
these urls are long
and annoying wouldn't it be much nicer
if i could say
something shorter you know it's a bit
more easier to remember how would i do
this on the web jake this is exciting
this would be import maps does it spot
import maps oh my god so basically you
can provide an import map as a file and
that i think is is really good again it
allows the signal you can really go in
on the web standard stuff and they keep
they keep keeping up with those as well
as far as i can tell they really keep an
eye out for the things that are useful
to them i'm actually now waiting for
them to do the
newer
import type assertions
and because that would solve the how do
i get a json in because currently i
think you have to go by reading why the
file apis well stuff's there in uh v8
now so
could it just work maybe i haven't
checked but you know and and i love
seeing this that they're keeping up with
it will also help solidify these
standards testing them out in more
scenarios
um this is exciting this is an exciting
future for like seeing where dino and
node
like
diverge where they converge i also saw
the no people talking about that they
actually they don't necessarily see dyna
as a competition it's a different take
on a similar problem space and they're
learning from each other and i love
seeing that that and i think maybe that
is why they were now starting to look at
streams a bit more and starting to ship
the what wg streams to node because just
it just makes sense to be more
compatible on that front node obviously
has the burden of being around for much
longer and having backwards
compatibility and all these things the
what wg streams didn't just appear out
of nowhere
you're being much better they learned
from the mistakes that that node had
made over a few iterations of their
streams so yeah yeah it's it's great to
see sort of circle of lives
um yeah and just as a quick tie up at
the end here's a couple of commands that
they can support because they really try
to come up with all batteries included
so they have a rebel you can run a file
um they have a pretty printer they have
a test runner and a test framework they
have a coverage tool
bundle is
a bit like parcel like rollup in that
they just inline all your static imports
into one big file if whether it's
standard library or something else it
just makes it one big script as an
optimization step i guess and what's
compiled do you tell me what compiles
compile is like bundle but it even
bundles dino itself so you get one
single statically linked binary that
contains your script which i think is
probably really interesting for all the
the back-end folks who want an easy time
deploying
something to a function or like a
a docker container put this one binary
in there you don't need a base image
it's just that one file it's very neat
um
it's still again the compile bit is
experimental which yeah it's it's
considered unstable but i tried it and
it worked i was kind of cool i obviously
didn't use it to a large
in a large project it's just that no a
script but yeah
i thought it's really cool it's like
obviously the binary is like i don't
know 70 megs or something but at the
same time you know size on the server
side matters less the ease of deployment
could matter more on that front makes it
easier to cache potentially as well or
to roll back a deployment i i could see
it really beneficial on on the back end
side for for folks
uh yeah if people want to know more the
website i do yeah well go right there
that's the url yeah.land is a proper top
level.land
and now i would like to see in the
comments how often i said danielhoff and
i said dino because i i don't even know
anymore
look look at the things we we couldn't
do before for a whole year i know we
couldn't cut our fingers off now we can
i couldn't tell you where your slide
clicker was it's just it's just
everything's back to normal
you couldn't put tape measure in my
mouth
it's look
i'm i'm just so glad we're back so glad
i'm sure people have missed this